Speaker 1: Things are really not going well for
many of the people who worked for Donald Trump,
but specifically for many of those people who
attempted to prosecute the voter fraud that they
claimed took place during the November of 2020
election. We're going to talk about Sidney Powell
in a moment. But first, I want to start with Rudy
Giuliani. We wondered for a while. Where did the
bogus stories about the 2020 election come from?
Like we understand who was spreading them. It was
Rudy, Steve Bannon, Trump himself, Sidney
Powell, Jenna Ellis, Fox News, Newsmax. Oh,
like we know who who was spreading them. But
where did a lot of this stuff surfaced from about
massive dumps of ballots and the wrong amount of
food being brought to overnight workers and the
water main break being fake, you know, like all
those who came up with it originally. There was
total lack of evidence for it wasn't subjected to
any real rigorous probing. It was just repeated.
But where did it come from? And at least as far
as Rudy Giuliani is now admitting under oath, at
least some of it was just stuff he saw on social
media. It's that humiliating. It's that pathetic.
It's that embarrassing. So let's take a look at
this report. Business Insider Rudy Giuliani admits
under oath that he got some of his evidence
of alleged election fraud from social media.
Rudy Giuliani admitted under oath that his
evidence of voter fraud in the 2020 election
in came partly from social media and that he
did not interview or fact check his sources.
Donald Trump's former personal lawyer made
the comments in a deposition on August 14
in relation to a defamation lawsuit brought
by a former Dominion Voting Systems employee,
Eric Coomer. First published by the Colorado
Sun, Coomer suing the Trump campaign and others
for promoting baseless conspiracy theories
that he helped quote rig the election for
Joe Biden. In the deposition, Rudy Giuliani
admitted that he got some of his information
about Koumas alleged role in the fraud from
his social media posts, but couldn't be sure
if it was Facebook or another platform.
Those social media posts? Get all one to me!
When questioned about whether he saw any other
evidence linking Huma with election fraud,
he responded, Right now, I can't
recall anything else. I laid eyes on.
The conspiracy theories about Coomer were sparked
by accusations made by right wing podcast host Joe
Altman. Altman claimed to have infiltrated
an antifa conference call in which someone
who identified themselves as Eric from Dominion
boasted about preventing Trump from winning the
election, according to the New York Times. Altman
offered no proof of his claims. The podcast host
then found Eric Koumas Facebook profile on which
he had supposedly written anti-Trump messages.
Rudy and other Trump allies seized upon Altman's
allegations, repeating them in the now infamous
infamous November 19 press conference. One of
the Smartmatic patent holders, Eric Coomer,
I believe his name is, is on the web as being
recorded in a conversation with Antifa members
saying that he had the election rigged for Mr.
Biden, according to court papers. Giuliani spent
virtually no time investigating the claims.
This is great. Giuliani said he was too busy
when asked why he repeated those claims without
verifying them. Giuliani said in the deposition,
It's not my job in a fast moving case to go out
and investigate every piece of evidence that's
given to me. Why wouldn't I believe him? I
would have to have been a terrible lawyer.
Gee, let's go find out if it's untrue.
I didn't have time to do or do that.
Trump has totally abandoned Rudy, as far as we can
tell. So there's really no advantage to Rudy lying
in this deposition. Right? His reputation is
in shambles. His finances are eroding away. He
might as well tell the truth under oath, and he
is telling the truth here. I believe, you know,
we joke about people's research. They say they've
researched the vaccine. They've researched the
election. It's not his job to investigate pieces
of evidence, which he later cites and presents
in court. And this is a lawyer who actually is
materially involved in this stuff. So when your
cousin's sister's cashier at the local job lot
says I've researched the vaccine, understand
what they mean by research, and understand even
Rudy here, saying, Look, I mean, I'm just I'm
I'm bringing this stuff to courts. I don't have
time to actually see if what I'm saying is true.
This is one of the biggest lies perpetuated
by right wing media for nearly the last year,
and some of the stuff started just something
Rudy saw on social media. He had every tool at
his disposal, but he went with what sounded the
wildest and most egregious that he came across
on his computer or his phone. And also remember,
Rudy wanted 20 grand a day from Trump to push all
of this stuff on the basis partially of stuff he
saw on social media. Funny, though, imagine that.
He's lying about where he got it, like I think
he's telling the truth. But imagine if saying
that it's from social media was to cover up
where he really got it and it's like somew